[موسيقى]
في قلبي منطقه لابوغون بشرق الفرنسي توجد
حديقه
تتربع على مساحه 400 هكتار
بها مئات الحيوانات التي تعيش في حريه
تامه كالايائل والغزلان البور والخنازير
البريه التي بامكان الزوار مشاهدتها عن
قرب حيوانات تتجول باريحيه دون اي حواجز
بينها وبين البشر
عندما نستقبل زوار
النخب الحيوانات
هي سيئه فلا يجب ازعاجها والعبور على هذه
المناطق التي تتغذى عليها حتى لا تفر كما
لا يجب الاقتراب منها كثيرا لابد من
احترام الحياه البريه للحيوان والحذر من
الجزء المخيف فيه
ملكه حديقه بوتيسان التي انشاتها عائلتها
لبوريون بعد ان اشترت في بدايه القرن
العشرين هذا الدير القديم وحديقته القاحله
انذاك
هذه الصوره لجده الكبرى هي التي حصلت على
ارض بوتيسه عام 1919
هذا جدي وجدتي عام 1919 كانت عباره عن
حديقه صغيره وفي الاخير تحولت الى غابه
طبيعيه مفتوحه في بادئ الامر لم تكن محاطه
بسياجات وليست بها حيوانات بعد ان وردها
ابي حولها الى حديقه طبيعيه
[موسيقى]
ضمن هذه الحياه البريه التي تم توفيرها
لهذه الحيوانات تظل هذه الاخيره في حاجه
الى الغذاء رغم عطاء الغابه المستمر حاجه
يكفلها حارس الحديقه الذي يسهر على منع
الصيف
هذه السنه لن يكون هناك كثير من الكستناء
والبلوط بسبب الجفاف تكمن المشكله في وجوب
احضار الغذاء لها على مدار العام لانها لا
يمكن ان تعتمد على نفسها كثيرا
ذلك مكلف جدا حيث تقدر ميزانيه السنويه
لطعام الحيوانات لحوالي 80 الف يورو
مقارنه بمعظم حيوانات الحديقه تعيش هذه
الايائل في مكان مغلق يحد من حريتها نوعا
ما
اجعلها تحت المراقبه التامه ويشجعها على
التكاثر
نود الحصول على ان الى صغيره مثل هذه
والتي ستصبح مثل تلك التي تبلغ 14 او 16
عاما بدورها ستصبح حين تكبر نحن نملك اجمل
الاشياء في فرنسا
على هذه الارض التي يقترب فيها البشر من
الحياه البريه اكثر من اي مكان اخر يعد
صوت الايلي اكثر ما يستهوي عشاق الطبيعه
ومصوري الحيوانات
انها السابعه الصباح يتنفس والشمس ترسل
اشعتها الاولى في الافق وكذلك يفعل بيان
يرسل خطاه بحذر مكتفيا اثار الاياء لي في
موسم التزاوج
لا يجب ان يفوت ادنى حركه عليه تحديد اي
مكان تنبعث منه الاصوات
مع قليل من الصبر يطل عليه ايل اخيرا
سينطلق اذا عمل المصور الفوتوغرافي
لا يجب ان يزعج الحيوان ابدا نبتعد عنه
بمسافه 50 مترا فقط تقريبا احب الاقتراب
منه كثيرا في امكاننا رؤيته حين يقترب حين
يعتدي على ايل اخر او حين يحاول ان يقفز
على الانثى التي تقترب منه حين نكون
قريبين جدا لا نرى مثل هذه الاشياء
التصوير الحيوانات من التخصصات النادره
التي قد تشعر فيها بالاحباط الشديد كما قد
تغمرك السعاده الكامله حين نجد السعاده
لابد ان نعيشها جيدا
عمل بيير لسنوات عديده في مجال الحياه
البريه فلم يجد سهوله كبيره كالتي عثر
عليها هنا حيث اعتادت الحيوانات على وجود
البشر بالقرب منها
انا لم اعد ابدا خاليه الوفاق من حديقه
بوتيسا على الحيوانات دائما وبما ان
مزاجها حسن في الغالب كذلك يسمح لي بالضبط
الجيد لاطار الصور وتحديد الاضاءه
المناسبه وتغيير مقاييس العدسات متى شئت
انه المكان الامثل لالتقاط صور الحيوانات
يغادر المصور الفوتوغرافي هذه الغابه وفي
جعبته اكثر من 500 صوره لن يعود الى في
العام المقبل لان الحديقه ستغرق ابوابها
امام الزوار لمده اربعه اشهر فتره مهمه
بالنسبه للحيوانات
تسلاها بالحياه البريه بعيدا عن انظار
الانسان